all right now let's keep going yeah I'm
gonna leave this proportion alone for a
second let's have a look at the average
because I think it's not that hard
in terms of proportions okay you're
still be working out much the same thing
you're gonna work out how much
population has changed okay you're still
gonna be dividing by the total time that
it took to get that change okay but to
turn this into a percentage right
suppose I did tell you all right we
gained 500 rabbits and it took five
years okay so that would tell you all
right a hundred hundred rabbits yeah
okay that isn't absolute okay that's an
absolute right so how'd I turn into a
proportional red what would you need to
do what extra informations you need to
know
so to give this
what are proportions you're like I am I
score and I scored 80% in this test
which is a 10% improvement on my
previous test okay so that's a
proportion that 10 was in that's a great
rate okay so what information do you
need to know to say oh I went up 10% you
the total what okay right now I'm
looking for a population of M all right
but the question is which population the
initial population right so when I said
okay
a hundred rabbits per year that could be
like saying we doubled the number of
rabbits we have cuz they're growing well
like it like rabbits okay so that would
be a 100% gain if I started 100 rabbits
per year right but maybe I started a
thousand rabbits per year okay so I'm
gonna be dividing by whatever this
number is okay that number is that
number right your initial population the
population no I'm not writing these
formulas for you to memorize in fact I
would actively encourage you not to
memorize them but so you can see what's
going on particular so you can see the
relationship between this one and radius
which binds everyone and the
relationship between this one and this
one you're just dividing by your initial
population or your initial mass or
whatever it is okay now
let's um I'm gonna leave this one to
last it's the weirdest one just did this
one because actually very easy if I want
to know the instantaneous rate of change
my population as a function of time okay
what is it it's just my dream right
so in fact
it's on the absolute without any
specific time put in okay that's why
it's still a function of time
okay last one yeah remember here we said
I want the rate of change in report to
that original population that I started
with okay now when we come over here
it's going to be important watching to
something else
it doesn't make much sense to say
initial population because here you
don't have two different points in time
an initial one and it ended all you've
got is one point I'm just one point in
time so if you're going to divide by
that hmm what you want is this rate of
change and you're gonna want to divide
by your population right peak make sense
it's not P of T 1 well I suppose we
could call it P of T we just have one
time right but it's not an initial time
versus an in time okay but stuff is in
here look at this look at it really
carefully okay you actually already know
exactly what this is equally it doesn't
really matter because as you'll see in a
second irrespective of time this is an
exponential growth indicator right
there's a relationship between TPM to T
and P what's the relationship between
these two
it's the equation which every single
question starts off with the first part
it says prove that this equation fits
this relationship this right
isn't this equal to K you don't usually
see it in this form usually you see it
in this form right it's the same
equation but I've just I've just moved a
little bit to make the ratio obvious
so therefore put the pair back in there
where I want okay when you want to know
and they'll actually say it in these
right the instantaneous growth rate in
proportion to your population at that
time all they are asking for is K that's
what they want I just want you know a
better way to ask it would be tell us
the constant of proportionality because
then it makes clear that what you're
after is can't even the constant which
as you can see has nothing to do with
time a completely separate okay but
sometimes and this is the really really
ultra frustratingly confusing part okay
sometimes they'll say this thing here
the question will say tell me the growth
rate and what they mean is tell me K
right so you see growth rate on its own
no other explanation of what it is they
mean K as opposed to get this the rate
of growth when okay so mm okay now you
see it's a first rate others because I
like referring a read of growth same
thing but there are clues in there to
help you understand on what's going on
for instance see growth rate right if
they don't give you a information apart
from that then it must be something
separate you tired does that make sense
because otherwise I don't have to tell
you well what value of T my one at fault
okay but he and I'll say rate of growth
when or in 1995 or when the population
hits such and such an amount so they're
actually looking for a specific value at
a specific time t1 okay so if there's a
time in here right you work out this but
there's no way to put that time into so
you know that's not the answer they're
after actually you just want to
differentiate the time okay